hi there Steve Kaufman here today I'm
gonna talk I'm gonna stray a little bit
not too far from the subject of language
learning and talk a little bit about
globalization the doubles conference
that's on right now and language
learning and remember if you enjoy these
videos please subscribe so what inspired
this is I'm watching when were down here
in Palm Springs my wife and I tend to
watch cable news along with our coffee
and toast for breakfast hmm and so this
morning I see the pictures of President
Trump in Davos where he's greeted like a
rock star everybody wants to selfie with
him because everybody's been basically
given such a large dosage of Trump in
the news that to see him in you know
live so to speak is is an event but you
know Davos globalization we hear so much
about globalization it's often painted
negatively that it's led to job losses
it's led to I don't know loss of
national identity and stuff which none
of it I believe I happen to believe that
globalization is inevitable historically
there's been this process of increasing
interconnectivity around the world and
what I find attractive what I enjoy
about the world we live in is just the
extent to which we can connect with
people from different parts of the world
and different languages and stuff like
that but Davos is kind of the you know
the the pinnacle the event the society
event of all the wealthy business people
and bankers and political people who
want to go there to be seen and and
again it reminds me of again this whole
idea of interconnectivity the wealthy
people who are their bankers business
people and stuff like that they are
there they are wealthy because of other
you can't be wealthy without having
access to raw materials which in most
cases you didn't put in the ground or
plant you can't be wealthy without
employees
some of whom work for miserable wages
you can't be wealthy without customers
we are all interconnected insofar as
trade products are made you know they
ship papayas from I don't know Mexico
Philippines and product is made in China
and and certain you know minerals might
come from Kazakhstan I mean we're in an
interconnected world geographically and
also in terms of whatever you know we
products we enjoy financial success that
these people at Davos have enjoyed it's
part of being connected internationally
connected it's these forces of
globalization yeah there have been sort
of disruptions certain types of jobs in
developed countries are no longer
available because they've been moved to
countries where you know wages are lower
but these are disruptions that we've
seen before people moved off the land
and used to be 95 percent of the people
on the land now it's 3 or 4 percent so
this is the kind of thing that it is not
unique to today but as I look at this
whole globalization thing and so these
people go to Davos to hobnob and rub
shoulders with other wealthy people and
to be seen at the bows and so forth and
it kind of reminds me of how the
polyglots get together and our Devoe's
which might be the polyglot conference
that richard cencon organizes or the
polyglot gathering that i attended that
bratislava or of course our own polyglot
gathering known as the long fest
festival day long
in montreal where people are happy to
get together and meet with people who
share a common interest and this
interest in languages to me is is as
rewarding in my
as this interest in money it affects
fewer people it's in a way perhaps more
selfish it's just those of us who are
learning languages of course we want to
encourage others to learn languages
whereas the business leaders at Davos
have a major impact on the economic
well-being of their employees or
customers and so forth so on and
interestingly you know Trump at Davos is
people want to have a selfie with Trump
and because they've seen him on TV so
often you know what
even me with my youtube presence you
know I was recently when I was in
Jerusalem I was in this market busy
market Friday at 2 o'clock there you
know mad shopping and they're about to
close for the Sabbath Shabbat and my
wife and I wanted to have a cup of
coffee when did this little coffee stand
and this guy says no so I said can we
have a macchiato
oh you're Steve Kaufman I watch you on
YouTube and of course if you've only
ever seen someone on YouTube or on
television when you see them live that's
kind of you know a bit of a of an event
so I guess the point I want to make is
languages now the other interesting
thing at Davos is you have different
countries there you have say Germany and
say India China okay two different
extremes in Germany the union's want to
have a twenty eight hour work week
already in Europe they work shorter
hours than in North America they have
longer holidays and now they want to
have this 20 hour
28 hour work week I don't know if
they'll get it I don't know what the
implications are but we used to have you
know ten-year-old children working 14
and 16 hours a day in the mines so it's
not impossible again as these changes
take place that ultimately we might have
a 28 hour work week you know it's like
it countries like Finland are
experimenting with a guaranteed income
to pay
so then the question is where do you
spend your free time once you've got so
much more free time what better place to
spend it than learning languages because
when you learn languages you can connect
you can connect geographically to
different parts of the world
you can connect historically there's no
question that as I study Arabic and I'm
only scratching a surface just getting
started I start to get a different
perspective on the Arab world and it is
my intention to continue from Arabic to
Farsi to Turkey Turkish on to Hindi and
since I already speak Chinese so then
I'm connected through the old Silk Road
into you know modern-day geography and a
connection back to history and so while
some people want to accumulate lots of
money and that has its benefits I think
there's a tremendous amount of reward in
learning languages learning languages
because of the things that we can learn
because of the sense of achievement that
it gives us the opportunity to connect
with people and with histories and with
cultures and you know we have the
example of Mark Zuckerberg who is the
founder of Facebook and was worth many
billions of dollars but what he really
wants to be able to do is to speak
Chinese so you know it's not evident
that those people at Davos with all
their money and their power and their
influence in terms of what they're able
to do every day with their lives how
they are able to enjoy every minute of
every day whether they are happier than
someone who is successful at learning
languages now maybe because I happen to
like learning languages and I have had a
certain amount of success doing that
that's not to say that I'm better than
someone who likes gardening or you know
whatever bird-watching I mean whatever
we choose to do if it gives us
satisfaction if it doesn't harm other
people it's a good thing but I would
like to
you know put in a plug for language
learning as a something that is
available to anyone because I definitely
believe that just as we can learn our
first language we can learn our second
third and fourth language if we put in
the time and if we are positive in our
attitude and so the rewards are great
it's a way to connect with the world
without having to go to the hosts and
without having to have a big bank
account so there you have it Davos
globalization and language learning bye
for now
oh and I forgot to mention that if you
would like to have a 30 minute
discussion with me about language
learning then please comment here about
what you would like to talk to me about
how you would like me to help you with
your language learning we are keeping
this little it's not a competition but
this event open and there will be a draw
on the 2nd of February bye for now
[Music]